so how does this game work we have to
say something nice or we lose yes then I
lost this election has been full of
insults and name-calling
it's almost as if we've forgotten what
Melania Trump wants plagiarized if you
can't think of anything nice to say
don't say it at all so can you think of
something nice to say say something nice
just one nice thing one nice thing just
say one nice thing
oh wow
I one night about him that he's leaving
soon
he's a very good singer he is he is the
first african-american to become
president I think that's a tremendous
trend as you are at the RNC right I also
know getting credit for going on college
campuses who say the college kids need
to cut it out with them sex rate people
more conservative points of views he
said it's not healthy for debate a lot
of respect for Obama for saying that I
like my are megyn kelly oh she's smart
she's intelligent what about this young
lady pass yeah she's funny
let me tell you anybody who makes it to
the level she has has had to overcome a
lot of hurdles and you know what no
matter what she says she's been
successful because she has realized what
her goal is
he likes to give jobs to interns
see what you did there I dunno he did
seem to genuinely feel people's pain
what I liked about him musta childcare
credit a few years ago we were coming
out of the Starbucks and we actually had
a conversation with him it was really
really nice guy
I'm positive if she is doing a great job
staying out of jail she knows how to
spin alive that sounds like me and
wrapped in
in terms of minority groups she has in
her political career done whole lot more
to help them being both First Lady and
Secretary of State compared to other
people
hey look they did it now was that so
hard